by the way that burned my ass in this
documentary he went and sued the guy who
took these pictures and said please do
not release pictures of me nude at nine
years old and when you say nude pictures
you were sexualized they put the makeup
on you the whole thing it made you look
like an adult and it was he waited till
I was famous to do it too which was just
gross but you know nowadays the norm is
different you if you went to court now
they would say this is Kitty Point
there's no way this guy's allowed to
release it but back then they were like
[__] you Brooke Shields I lost and and
the the prosecuting attorney who was
just such a prick you know was like
making little gestures to me and and
nobody was seeing it and it was so
surreal and what do you mean Lou just
like he would lick his lips and look at
me and say things like you were thinking
of fornication weren't you and I was
like I thought it was fornification but
no I was like this I was so naive but I
no at nine years old we were doing a
dress-up we were a little kid in one
picture and then we were an adult in the
other so naked and I got the bathtub
assignment but I wasn't I walked around
nuded as a nine-year-old I wasn't I
didn't have budding sexuality I didn't
have I wasn't but when you're 15 and
you're in high school and then to bring
those out it was embarrassing and that's
the crazy thing with your mom that I
can't figure out she had this like crazy
justification for things like she
believed that as long as she was in my
personal life keeping me safe and and
and and and virginal and pure and all
that that she was sparing me you know
she just she believed her own you know
the the scene where she's teaching me
how to swim yeah
she doesn't know how to swim she dies
not knowing how to swim and I I saw that
and I was like holy hell
she's I believed she could walk on water
let alone you know swim and I'm looking
at that thinking the woman never learned
how to swim but boy she taught me
how to swim and it was just that's the
way she lived her life you know when you
finally sort of divorced your mother and
asserted your Independence
it feels good I guess but it also feels
bad because you have a lot is she guilty
yeah you have guilt guilt and and fear
and sadness because you know you know
you know she could play the Martyr and
say you see everybody leaves me you know
and she was sort of raging and couldn't
believe I left her in such a violent way
and
um and I I had tried doing it systematic
desensitization but it wasn't going to
work with her nothing was ever not
extreme with her and then she said to
Lisa my best friend from high school
she's like Brooke you're not going to
believe she said your mom looked at me
and said but that took balls oh so she
was proud maybe she was you know I she
saw the fighter in me and although she
was angry I think she was like all right
she's she's not a wimp the kid you know
and I think she she had to give me props
because it was really a ballsy thing I I
gutted the her office I took everything
overnight
um and you know it was it was a very
difficult thing for her to witness
happening